planetside 2 on the PlayStation 4
doesn't make a great first impression
whether you are new to the game or have
transitioned from the PC version if
you're new the lack of direction can
make the first moments daunting tooltips
give you some basics upon your first
interactions with various terminals and
menu screens but there are terms and
mechanics you must come to grips with
and the best way to do that is to
undergo trial by fire if you're
transitioning from the PC there are
other obstacles to overcome many of them
are minor but there are enough of them
to make you pause and wonder whether
these issues shouldn't have been solved
after all planetside 2 is approaching
its three-year anniversary on the PC it
often takes menus several seconds to
respond making you wonder if a button
press didn't register the visuals are
also a notable downgrade of sensible
sacrifice to keep the framerate stable
unfortunately plan aside to occasionally
stutters and hitches during the most
intense battles making the compromise
sometimes hard to swallow on the other
hand planetside 2 special moments are
too special to let these encroaching
shadows envelop the game in darkness yes
you would reasonably expect the full
release to perform better and to have
swiped away the simple bugs that
occasionally crawl into view such as the
way the reddish arcs that indicate
you've been hit may not disappear or the
infrequent but irritating hard crashes
but when the war heats up
there's nothing exactly like planetside
2 a massively multiplayer shooter in
every sense of the term the world and
its continents are open and persistent
inviting combatants to fight for control
over the facilities scattered across the
expanses you engage others by taking to
the air and engaging in dogfights
by roaring forward and tanks and by
joining fellow infantry and rushing into
ground battle you're hooked up with a
squad as soon as you log in and while my
fellow players aren't nearly as vocal or
as coordinated on the ps4 as they are on
the PC it's two planetside twos credit
that you can get involved in warfare
mere seconds after entering the world
and thus the battle rages ever
on you and other comrades hop into a
transport vehicle called a Sunderer you
trundle towards your destination and
deploy near a facility hoping that the
terrain protects the vehicle from any
heavy troops nearby from here the pace
of battle changes depending on where the
struggle occurs a base nestled in the
hills gives rise to clever sniping and
streams of infantry that participate in
the tug of war as one faction pushes
upwards and the other heads downwards to
stop it a flat approach on the other
hand gives rise to a daunting river of
tanks flowing as one unit towards the
contested base tanks have a nice heft to
them making it fun to roll over hills
and launch artillery at oncoming
vehicles on the flip side launching a
missile into one of those tanks watching
it explode and hearing that rewarding
audio tinkle that alerts you to
experience earned is a consistent treat
not every moment you spend in planetside
2 is in the midst of a massive firefight
however there are uneventful stretches
in which you and your squad capture
facilities with little resistance or
amble ahead and tanks for many minutes
on end wishing there was something to
shoot back at your factions primary base
you might spend some time deciding how
to spend the certification points you've
earned during your hours and days of
battle this is your primary currency and
as is the case with so many free-to-play
games this currency accumulates slowly
after the initial hours when you feel
vulnerable even when surrounded by the
solid armor of a lightning tank it's
only natural that you'd want to
reinforce it and when certs are slow to
come spending real-world money is a
temptation especially when a paid
membership lets you bypass the login
views like so many big games with dozens
of complex moving parts your enjoyment
of planetside 2 on the PlayStation 4
rests on how forgiving you are of
technical pick ups that you would
properly expect to be vanquished it's
hard to miss those big problems but you
will temporarily forget about them when
battle is underway at these moments the
troubles fade away leaving only the
frights and delights of planetary war